covering the mountainside in modest Peru  thousands of man-made ponds sit exposed  to the elements as they have for over  500 years  [Music]  we need the Kaka we need a mountain  where these salt pants it runs a salt  filled underground spring the pan each  no more than a foot deep fill with this  natural spring water which the Sun  evaporates leaving behind the natural  salt  created between 500 and a thousand ad it  was the Incans who built them up into  what we see today currently there are  over 3,000 active pans each one owned by  a different family in the modest  community and our hand mined much the  same as when the Incans were here each  pool yields about 330 pounds of salt per  month when the salt has been mined the  pool is refilled and the process begins  again visiting these pans allows you to  marvel at the beauty of nature and of  man ingenuity  [Music]